democrats continue to troll as the trump
team tries to lay out their legal case
the media continue their never-ending
quest to cover for joe biden's picks
and a prominent actress declares herself
a man i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government's
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first you're spending
way too much money on your cell phone
bill how do i know well because you're
paying for unlimited
data aren't you aren't you well you can
be getting the exact same coverage
from the exact same cell towers as one
of those big companies and be doing it
for like half the price if you were
using
puretalk usa you don't have to sacrifice
customer service their team is based
right here in the us
some of the nicest people you will ever
talk to you can get unlimited talk text
and two gigs of data for just 20 bucks a
month
and if you go over on that data usage
they're not going to charge you for it
see most of these other companies they
sort of fuss around when they're telling
you what exactly your plan covers and
they'll tell you you need unlimited data
you probably don't need
unlimited data in fact you almost
certainly don't need unlimited data what
you need
is unlimited talk text and two gigs of
data and you're doing it for like half
the price
of the other big companies pure talk usa
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
50 off your first month dial pound 250
say
keyword ben shapiro puretalk is simply
smarter wireless
go check them out right now by dialing
pound 250 and saying
keyword ben shapiro to save 50 off your
first month and save
month on month every month for the rest
of time go check them out
right now dial pound 250 and say keyword
ben shapiro
to get started okay so one of the things
that members of the media have been
noticing
is that there are a lot of trump
supporters who don't seem to trust the
outcome of the election now they're
treating this with a great deal of shock
which is kind of amazing since
as of like 2017 a vast majority of
democrats suggested that the 2016
results
have been actively warped by not only
russian meddling but by russian boat
hacking
there was serious doubt as to the
electoral veracity of the 2016 election
from democrats and now it's 2020 and now
republicans have questions
about the electoral veracity of the 2020
election and some of that is based on
bad information that's out there and
some of that is based on the fact that
what we saw across the country at least
in a huge number of swing states
were vastly different voting procedures
than we have ever seen before
procedures changed to allow millions of
mail-in votes whereas before you
actually had to request an absentee
ballot now it was just sent to your
house in some of these states
we saw procedures changed to the effect
that over 50 percent of votes in many of
these states were actually coming in
early
i'm not a fan of early voting because
there's often late breaking news
that affects exactly how you are going
to vote i mean there's a good shot that
for example the modern vaccine numbers
had been announced the week before the
election
and then people had been voting on
election day that might have made a
difference
okay so a lot of the procedures change
there's a lot of
ballot harvesting in various states
there are a lot of open questions
and more than that when we really talk
about the fact that both sides and it
really is a both side's thing
both sides don't trust election results
that don't swing their way
that goes to the lack of trust that is
now undergirding our political system
and that lack of trust pre-existed
donald trump there's something that's
been going on in the united states for a
very long time
and that is that one side of the
political aisle has been castigating his
evil the other side of the political
aisle and then the other side of the
political aisle began to think okay if
they're castigating me as evil maybe
they're the ones who are evil
there's some interesting poll statistics
starting in the 1990s showing that while
republicans mostly saw democrats as
people they disagreed with
democrats mostly saw republicans as
people who were morally bigoted and
morally wrong
and then around 2008 2009 you started to
see republican feelings about democrats
shoot up into the stratosphere you saw
them starting to match democratic
numbers with regard to how much they
thought the democrats were not just
wrong
democrats were morally wrong and we've
been there basically ever since
and that is the result of a long-time
campaign to cascade one side of the
political aisle
as morally bereft and to gaslight
everybody
and so one of the things that has
happened also is that a media
infrastructure which now insists that
the election was absolutely pure and
clean as the driven snow and there was
no voter fraud anywhere
which is not necessary in order for them
to ensure that joe biden
maintains the the vote and becomes
president-elect right all the democrats
have to show
really and all the media have to say is
sure there was voter fraud sure there
was voter irregularity but it doesn't
amount to the sort of numbers
that would shift the election that is a
fairly well-justified statement given
the facts that are currently on the
ground but they're not doing that
instead they are saying that there is no
voter fraud and no voter irregularity
the same media
who declared that that the voting
systems that die bold voting machines
were hacked in 2004 and took that
absolutely seriously that suggested for
several years on end
that president trump was an illegitimate
president right paul krugman called
trump illegitimate and then like two
days ago he tweeted out nobody ever
called trump illegitimate
that sort of gaslighting is apt to make
people wary about trusting
the system see when you think that your
opponents are morally bad
and not only that when you see the
possibility of
some sort of crime to shift the results
of elections you're going to start to
get wary
and i i think a lot of republicans look
at this election cycle this is not to
say that they are
right about the results of the election
and as we will see
the evidence of voter fraud and voter
irregularity there there is evidence
that it has happened
there is not evidence to suggest that it
overwhelms the numbers of vote
differentials that we see in states like
michigan or pennsylvania or georgia or
arizona for example
but when republican voters when
conservatives look at the
situation across the country and they
say here are a bunch of democrats who
have said that they want to
remake the united states senate that
they want to get rid of the electoral
college that they want to stack the
supreme court
and we've had situations in the past in
very narrow elections where we know
that democrats have engaged in soft
forms
of voter irregularity at the very least
the one that comes to mind here is norm
coleman losing his senate seat in
minnesota to al franken
that actually created the 60th senate
seat for obamacare
when republicans look at that and they
say okay they had the motive right if
they could cheat to stop trump would
they cheat
see their poll statistics showing that
actually about 40 percent of democrats
think that if democrats could have
cheated they would have cheated
right that was a gallup poll recently so
there's a high level of
mistrust in the other side there's
motive
is there opportunity well maybe there's
opportunity given all of the shifting
variables of the vote counts given the
fact that you have these heavy mail-in
votes
given the fact that we've never seen
anything like this in terms of the
mail-in voting and the universal
balloting we've never seen turnout like
this
at least not for a century so they have
the motive and the opportunity
and the question is do they have the
means right so did this happen right
usually a crime is motive means
opportunity did they have the motive
means opportunity we know they have the
motive
and we don't know about the means and
the opportunity yet i think that what
team trump is trying to show
is they had the the opportunity but they
really haven't shown the means and they
haven't shown that the actual crime
occurred
to the extent necessary to reverse the
results of these elections thus far
right but the motive itself is the
rationale for why you are seeing this
vast political divide
because if you believe that the other
side is willing to cheat wouldn't you be
suspicious
that they did cheat right and so when
people
kind of treat everybody who's suspicious
about the election as a rube or an idiot
that seems to be missing the point to me
and the point here is that you have
spent
years on end suggesting that you're
willing to break any rule
you're willing to do anything in pursuit
of donald trump
so why exactly would you suspect that
republicans would suddenly buy into him
losing
legitimately especially when the polls
seem to be so wrong in so many states
and especially when republicans
overperform the polls everywhere you can
understand
on a personal level why trump would look
and say okay hold on republicans
did really well across the country i'm
the only one who didn't do well i'm the
most
well-known republican in the country why
now listen there's a countervailing
logic here which is that trump is the
most polarizing political
figure of any of our lifetimes that
donald trump
has probably more haters than he does
people who absolutely love him
right and so there's an alternative
explanation which is that yes he drove a
lot of people to the polls but he also
drove a lot of people to the polls
against him right that is perfectly
plausible as well
but to understand why people are so
invested in the election fight you have
to understand the gaslighting that has
been going on for years
and the moral consternation that has
been directed at conservatives and
republicans
for years so to take an example so
barack obama
now considered widely by the media as a
moderate unifying president which is
just insane because we are all old
enough to remember
barack obama being president he was not
moderate and he was not unifying he was
deeply divisive
i think in many ways the 2012 election
broke the country because i think that
barack obama in 2004 campaigned
as a moderate unifying figure that was
his 2004 dnc speech go back and watch it
it sounds more like george w bush
even though he's campaigning for john
kerry it sounds more like george w bush
than it does like barack obama circled
2010.
go back to his 2008 campaign and he was
campaigning as captain unity
then in 2010 he started to realize that
if he could cast
all of his political opponents as
villains in a morality play
where he was standing for a new racially
multicultural system
and his opponents were standing for
bigoted american racism
and he was the person who's going to
transform the system then he could still
win election
even though he had significant
opposition wasn't doing a particularly
good job
and then he won in 2012 on that basis
that president that very very divisive
president a president who routinely
disparaged the constitution
that suggests the constitution of the
united states was a barrier to progress
in the united states
a president who himself declared
repeatedly that he did not have the
constitutional power
to simply not enforce immigration law
and then decided you know what i'm just
going to go ahead and do it anyway and
then declared he was not going to
enforce immigration law with regards to
deferred action for childhood arrivals
the daca program
now barack obama is going on his book
tour this book includes
a bunch of rips on the american system
it includes the basic idea that everyone
who opposed him was a racist
and yet he is being propped up by the
media as somebody
who has nothing but moral
leisure domain to say exactly what he
pleases he is a person
with unending moral certitude and he's
being granted
unlimited moral capital by the media so
here is barack obama
saying to stephen colbert an absolute
sycophant
he's no longer even a pretend comedian
stephen colbert he's just an absolute
democratic sick offense that's all he
does for a living
he's no different than brian stelter at
this point here is stephen colbert with
barack obama and barack obama saying
that he should have known that the
constitution didn't have to be followed
well
you did know that which is why you
consistently violated it but it's this
sort of stuff that drives republicans up
a wall to the point where they say we
don't trust the media we don't trust the
systems designed by democrats and we
don't trust the media to talk about
systems that are very often designed
by democrats or lauded by democrats here
is barack obama again driving people up
a wall
we found out from your successor that
there's a whole bunch of stuff you don't
actually have to do and people still can
see you're president
do you look at another like i didn't
have to do any of that stuff i know i
don't do the stuff
are there any things that he chucked out
you went oh if only i'd known i didn't
have to
do that i think there's a lot i thought
respond to subpoenas yeah follow follow
uh
the constitution um yeah that's a drag
okay the idea that barack obama was a
constitutional president i mean stephen
colbert is such a damned joker
what a liar and a joker he is my
goodness and the idea that the barack
obama
followed the constitution or had one
ounce of anything beyond sustained for
the constitution
is a it's a laughable joke and it drives
people up a wall it drives people nuts
it drives me up a wall i wrote an entire
book about how barack obama did not
follow the constitution over and over
and over again
barack obama's suggesting that i love
that stephen colbert says to barack
obama's face you know did you know that
you didn't have to respond to subpoenas
he literally invoked executive privilege
to stop
eric holder from having to testify and
turn over documents in fast and furious
yes barack obama was very well aware he
did not have to respond to subpoenas
and by the way in very many cases it
turns out constitutionally the executive
does not have to respond to all
subpoenas that are put forth by the
legislature but the basic idea here that
barack obama was a great defender of the
constitution while donald trump
is some sort of great underminer of the
constitution is nuts
it's nuts and when you get told over and
over again that things that are not true
are true and that people who violated
the constitution are actually
constitutional defenders and people who
are deeply divisive like barack obama
and sneer at the american people like
barack obama are actually defenders of
the common man and the constitution
at a certain point you too are going to
say to hell with all of this i don't
believe anything you have to tell me
up to and including your sudden belief
in the american electoral system
remember just about six weeks ago before
the election
democrats were the ones who were out
there saying that the electoral system
was rigged they were saying
that donald trump was going around
burning mailboxes and removing them from
street corners
and now they flip on a diamond they say
the election is absolutely clean you can
see why people are a little suspicious
now listen suspicion doesn't mean that
the election gets overturned you
actually have to prove in court your
case
but to pretend that people have no real
emotional reason to be to be
suspicious or concerned that's
ridiculous of course they have reason to
be suspicious and concerned
to pretend that the american people are
supposed to just accept on a dime the
media shift from
trump's going to steal the election to
trump definitely was unable to steal the
election and biden didn't steal the
election
it's a pretty wild shift is it not the
shift from barack obama is the greatest
unifying incredible figure of all time a
constitutional president
to joe biden will be exactly that and
donald trump was an outlier
like we all know that you people are
lying we know that you are lying and we
know democrats are lying and we know
that the media are abetting
those lies we're gonna get to more of
this in just one second because this is
my firm belief is that barack obama
drove the country insane and we've been
basically insane ever since and the
media were complicit in this
and barack obama doing his book tour
right now and repeating lie after lie
after lie about america about his own
administration about what he was as
president
and the media just parroting that crap
all that's doing is spinning this stuff
up
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that it is indeed doorbell season the
busiest time of year at your front door
that is definitely true at my house
right now
there are just more packages arriving at
the front door holiday gifts and things
that we have to buy in preparation
for hanukkah i know that's happening at
your door too my kids i have three of
them
under seven they're all running around
the house at all times my little one
she's so squishy and cute
but she is now crawling which means that
we have to keep an eye on her at all
times because she will find anything and
put it in her mouth well there's only
one of me
and there are three of them they are as
i like to call them the army of the
children
this means that i actually have to keep
an eye on them thank you to ring the
ring devices allow me
to keep an eye on all three of my
nefarious
my nefarious military based children
go check out ring right now for a
limited time go to ring.com forward
slash ben for special holiday offers
ring has everything you need to keep an
eye on home this holiday season and
throughout the year
see and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with video doorbells keep
an eye
on every corner of your house with easy
to install indoor and outdoor cams help
protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install it yourself
as soon as we move my wife's first first
words out of her mouth where we need to
get the ring devices on the house like
immediately and we did
you should too ring.com forward slash
ben go check them out right now
ring.com forward slash man keep your
family safe the ringway
ring.com forward slash ben okay so it is
not just barack obama
engaging in this sort of gaslighting
susan rice who lied to the american
people repeatedly about benghazi you'll
recall that she suggested
that it was essentially a spontaneous
expression of rage
and a random youtube video it was
ridiculous
susan rice who is a radical on foreign
policy radically anti-israel
radically against american power exerted
in the world
she certainly was no friend to
transparency and susan rice
who wrote an outgoing document on the
way out of the white house saying and by
the way we did everything right on this
russia probe bye catch you later
note to file we are amazing right susan
rice
friend of democracy she writes a piece
today in the new york times called our
democracy's near-death experience
no time is no now is no time for
complacency the next congress must
shore up our institutions it appears our
democracy dodged a bullet or more
precisely multiple concerted efforts by
the president
to torpedo its very foundations now
again
hearing from democrats about torpedoing
the foundations of the democracy after a
three and a half year campaign
to oust president trump based on russian
collusion bullcrap
is pretty rich it's pretty rich but
i'm up for it i mean let's be lectured
on democracy by susan rice
she says while president trump rages
relentlessly about election fraud
many republican leaders continue to pair
false denials of the validity of
president-elect joe biden's clear
victory
yet so far our democracy has withstood
the greatest stress test of our
lifetimes
okay this is not the greatest stress
test of our lifetime it's not even close
to the greatest stress test of our
lifetimes
i mean seriously i would say that covid
is a greater stress test of the
democracy considering how many
individual liberties have been violated
by state and local actors
than anything that trump has done with
regard to the election the systems have
held
we have courts in place state
legislatures have voted to certify
governors have voted to certify this
this stress test has not been
particularly compelling
frankly in terms of the impact that it
has done to the system itself
and when we were talking about stress to
the constitution of the united states it
seems to me
that obamacare which mandated that you
buy insurance
for your health insurance right the
obamacare mandate which was
unconstitutional in the extreme was more
of a stress test for the constitution
than anything that donald trump has done
as president of the united states but
that's not susan rice's case she is a
defender of democracy guys and you
should trust her
because she is trustworthy she says mr
trump and his political allies have been
employing nearly every weapon at their
disposal to try to retain the white
house
notwithstanding the will of the people
she says trump supporters work
deciduously to suppress the vote by
denigrating the legitimacy of mail-in
ballots during a pandemic
okay so we're still gonna go these same
people who keep saying
that the vote was the cleanest ever
they're also saying that trump was
responsible for voter suppression
remember these are the same
joker jackals who suggest that stacy
abrams is the actual governor of georgia
thanks to no information whatsoever of
voter suppression
in georgia not one thing that she
mentions here actually undermines
democracy by the way
not one right she talks about first the
trump campaign labored to concoct bogus
conspiracy theories to discredit biden
by falsely smearing his son hunter
falsely smearing where is the smear
seriously what was the smear
that hunter biden was a bag man for
himself and maybe for other members of
the family
seems pretty well substantiated that's
not a smear
she says trump supporters work to
denigrate mail-in balloting by saying
that it's corrupt
to send people mail-in votes without
them requesting it
that doesn't seem like it's undermining
democracy that seems actually kind of
plausible does it not
i mean i moved from california to
florida i voted in florida my old
address in california received mail-in
votes
i received mail-in ballots i didn't use
them obviously
but they were out there that's not a
good thing she says third
some of trump's most ardent supporters
intimidated voters at the polls heating
calls to stand by and go into the polls
and watch very carefully they deployed
sometimes armed in black and brown
communities under the guise of ensuring
no fraudulent votes were cast okay if
you actually engage in voter
intimidation that's criminal activity
and will be prosecuted
there are plenty of political people who
are at the polls standing outside of the
demarcated line beyond which you are not
allowed to do
politics and it shows fourth in the
run-up to election day trump dispatched
an army of litigants to enlist the
courts in curtailing access to the polls
oh you mean that he filed lawsuits
which is like the definition of doing a
legal thing since you are now filing
lawsuits
but she says that this undermined
democracy so
what do we have to do what do we have to
do she says the lesson we must learn is
not a reassuring one a determined
autocrat in the white house poses a
grave threat to our democratic
institutions
and can severely undermine faith in our
elections particularly when backed by
partisans in congress
oh you don't say i look forward to
hearing how democrats plan
to alleviate this problem of autocrats
in the white house overrunning the
boundaries of the constitution
and perverting the american people's
perspective on what the values of the
united states are tell me more
obama administration official so she
says what is the solution
to vote out republican incumbent
senators in georgia
that's the answer because then congress
can apply some of its lessons
so for example they could enact before
the people act to combat corruption
strengthen ethics rules and improve
voter access as well as the john lewis
voting rights advancement act to restore
the protections of the 1965 legislation
that would require by the way the
federal government to give pre-clearance
to redistricting in a variety of
southern states
so be good democrats could now draw the
district despite the fact that states
are given the power to draw the
districts that would be the idea here
from susan rice
also if you elect democrats to the
georgia senate
according to susan rice you can fix all
the problems with the system presumably
by getting rid of the electoral college
or moving to do so by packing the
supreme court which is something the
democrats have been threatening to do
and by willy-nilly adding states like
puerto rico and washington dc to the
senate thereby stacking
the senate in favor of democrats yeah
all of that is definitely going to short
democracy
why do people have trust issues guys i
don't get it why do people have trust
issues
and meanwhile the media continue to
demonstrate why people have trust issues
by defending
literally everything that any democrat
will ever do
so for example the incoming biden team
right one of the people who is going to
be joining that team
is jen saki okay and jennifer sackey
is a long time obama era official she
was at the state department we've talked
about her on the show then she went to
cnn which is basically just moving over
to the pr department for the democratic
party and the obama administration now
she's moving back into government
because there's that revolving door
again okay so over the past why don't
people trust the system guys
so over the past 24 hours a picture
emerged that she tweeted out it's her
own damn fault because she's an idiot
she tweeted out a picture of herself
meeting with russian officials
wearing one of those kind of furry
russian hats whose names i don't
remember and on the front of it
was the russian red like the soviet
you're a red star with a hammer and
sickle on the hat
was a pink hat with the soviet era red
star with the hammer and sickle
okay and usa today so people on the
right started tweeting this out saying
yeah that sounds like not a person i
want in charge of
communications okay that sounds like not
great
okay so usa today fact checked the photo
right here is usa today's fact check why
don't we trust our media
the claim a photo shows jen sackey joe
biden's pick for press secretary wearing
a hammer and sickle hat while posing
with officials from russia
our ruling missing context that is not a
fact
check okay a fact check is false or true
not missing
context missing context is a political
spin by definition
if i say two plus two equals four and
you say fact check missing context like
well
no first you have to evaluate whether
the claim itself is true it is true
it is true matt wolking a spokesperson
for
president trump took to twitter and
shared that photo he said here's gen
saki hugging russia's foreign minister
and russia's chief foreign affairs
propagandist while wearing a pink hammer
and sickle hat
and apparently the so usa today
fact-checked this and they said well you
know it's missing
context what exactly is the context the
context is that she was pictured with
then secretary of state john kerry and
officials from russia foreign minister
sergey lavrov and foreign ministry
spokesperson maria
zacharova they just completed a
diplomatic meeting in paris as part of a
run-up to peace talks
and they brought unusual gifts like
harry brought idaho potatoes for lavrov
and lavrov had a gift for saki i i i
failed to see how this undermines the
fact check
why is that missing context that is not
missing context that's a reality like
the fact that it never occurred to her
hey maybe it's a bad idea to put on a
hat
with a logo that represents the murder
of tens of millions of human beings
that should say something but no don't
worry jen sackey is wonderful the media
have told us so and we must trust the
media we must trust them
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that you hear
stories in the news all the time where a
good guy has to protect his family or
his life or his property
with a gun and then he ends up being
dragged into court he ends up being
prosecuted you need to know your rights
when it comes to gun ownership you need
legal defense if god forbid you actually
have to fire
a weapon in your own defense this is why
you should hook up with the great folks
over at the us concealed carry
association if you're a gun owner you
have to be aware of self-defense laws
where you live
it's not responsible to own a firearm
and not know the legal ramifications of
using it
what you need is the complete concealed
carry and family defense guide from the
us concealed carry association it is 100
free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun even if you have little kids
and a whole lot more it's 164-page guide
loaded with valuable information just
text ben
287 222 to get started you'll get
instant access and a chance to win a
thousand bucks so you can buy a gun to
protect your family text ben
to 87 222 right now again text my name
ben 287
222 my name been to 87 222 and get
started with my friends over at the us
cca doing a great job making sure
that armed citizens our knowledgeable
citizens text ben to 87
222. so again the media's coverage of
john sackey here's the new york times
take on john sackey you ready for that
okay by the way
should mention jen saki responded to
this photo of jen saki posted by jen
saki of janzaki wearing
a hat with a hammer and sickle on it by
tweeting this quote
for anyone who hasn't been the target of
russian propaganda the purpose is to
discredit powerful messengers
and to spread misinformation to confuse
the public anyone who repeats it is
it anyone who repeats it is unwitting or
not simply a puppet
of the propaganda machine oh my god this
is so rich so a few a few notes
one the entire democratic infrastructure
repeated the propaganda that donald
trump was a russian tool for three years
for three years everyone in the media
everyone so were they all
unwitting tools of the russian
propaganda machine
second thing she posted the photo
in the first place that's not russian
disinformation you don't just get
like this is this is the part that's
going to drive everybody up a wall is
that the media proclaim that shenzhaki
is actually a representative of truth
but according to gensaki
jensaki posting a photo of john saki
posing
wearing a hat with a hammer and sickle
on it is russian disinformation
i mean that's some real deep cover right
there the russians somehow got to
gensaki
several years ago to post disinformation
that would be used against gensaki later
the russians are so good at this crap
they went back in time and they somehow
turned gensake of 2014
so that gensake in 2020 would be in
trouble now
but don't worry guys she is an expositor
of pure truth
here's the new york times's take on
gensaki
mr biden's choice of jennifer sackey 42
a veteran of the obama administration
who is generally viewed by reporters as
fair and accessible
as his chief spokeswoman embodies that
return to normalcy approach
mr biden official said was particularly
drawn to miss saki by her background at
the state department
there she worked under secretary of
state john kerry and grew comfortable
delivering 90-minute briefings on
foreign policy issues
like a dispute over the south china sea
at the white house saki intends to bring
back
daily press briefing which has all but
been phased out over the past four years
it is not clear however when those
sessions might resume given the
constraints of the pandemic
but miss saki views a central part of
her job as restoring faith
in the words spoken from behind the
podium the clown games are over said
susan rice
who went out on national tv and lied to
the american people over and over about
benghazi
jen will represent the professionalism
and decency and commitment to
transparency that has been a hallmark of
joe biden's career yes when i think of
joe biden i think of a transparency a
commitment to transparency particularly
with regards to mbna
and other credit card companies located
in delaware who are basically helping to
finance
his real estate purchases in sweetheart
deals
he's captain transparency as joe biden
who knew who knew but don't worry guys
they're going to tell you the truth
about the election
now again does this mean does any of
this mean
that the election has been proved to be
fraudulent
no you should have to prove that in
court but can you see why people might
be just a tad suspicious when the media
overwhelmingly proclaimed that the
election was fine there's a knee-jerk
reaction
that is understandable which is if the
media says it it probably isn't true
i get it i do i understand it here's
another example of this so janet yellen
right she's been widely praised by the
media as a consensus pick now she served
under
barack obama as the federal reserve
chairperson
right and uh there she was you know very
much in favor of a sort of inflationary
approach
to the currency she's very much in favor
of lowering interest rates
well yesterday she did a presser in
which she talked about
using the treasury department in order
to promote certain goals now last i
checked the treasury department was
basically there to ensure the stability
of the american currency that's what the
treasury department is there to do not
according to janet yellen it's not
according to janet yellen a moderate
figure well beloved by wall street
according to your mainstream media
she says that she's going to use the
treasury department to resolve
racial inequality and climate change
she doesn't explain how but sure grab
control of the nation's monetary supply
and use it to press forward
your particular brand of radical
politics that sounds like a real
moderate thing to me here is janet
yellen being a
quote unquote moderate out of our
collective pain
as a nation we will find collective
purpose
to control the pandemic and build our
economy back
better than before to rebuild our
infrastructure
and create better jobs to invest in our
workforce
to advance racial equity and make sure
the economic recovery
includes everyone to address the climate
crisis
with american ingenuity and american
jobs
oh so we're just going to blow money
through a leaf blower basically
to favored members of the biden
coalition but don't worry she's a
moderate guide she's
she's a total total moderate and why
exactly would we have doubts about
electoral veracity
when it comes to the fact that we still
have we are now over a uh
about a month away from the election
right today is december 2nd
the election happened november 3rd
they're still counting votes in places
like new york and iowa not kidding
and it's getting pretty dicey in these
vote counts according to politico
a month after election day razor thin
congressional elections in an open
southeast iowa seat
and the upstate new york seat held by
democratic representative anthony
brandisi are still unresolved
with democrats barely trailing in both
districts the implications are unusually
serious in a tightly divided house
the latest blow for democrats came
monday when iowa official certified
republican marionette miller meeks as
the winner of her race after a recount
found her leading democrat rita hart by
just six votes out of 394
000 cast .002 percentage points
when we began this recount rita hart was
down by 47 votes heart campaign manager
zach meunier said in a statement monday
as more iowans voices were heard the
margin has narrowed dramatically and is
now down to a mere six votes
making this the closest congressional
race in recent history and one of the
very closest
in the last 100 years heart of course
says that she is going to launch
a legal challenge meanwhile a recount
has yet to begin in new york where the
disorganized decentralized election
system
has meddled the outcome of a close
rematch between brendisi and former gop
representative claudia tenney currently
separated by roughly a dozen votes
there's still a thousand ballots
remaining in dispute or uncounted
including large numbers of
provisional ballots and these ballots
are suspiciously trickling in
just in time to be counted our campaign
is committed to seeing that all and only
legal votes count said sean kennedy a
tenney spokesperson
the voters will must be respected and
the integrity of the election process
maintained so what exactly is happening
in new york this one this one's real
rich okay a new york state judge
is reviewing updated county vote totals
on monday afternoon before setting the
next steps which could include a
re-canvas
so excellent we're going to have a new
york state judge presumably a democrat
look over all of the balloting yeah this
shouldn't make you suspicious like at
all
it's all going to be fine it's all going
to be fine
meanwhile over in iowa hart has two days
to contest under state law
now that i was board of canvas certified
miller mixes win her challenge would be
referred to a judicial panel
that would include the iowa state
supreme court justice to determine the
victor of the election
meanwhile the house could simply refuse
to seat miller meeks and create a
committee to review the matter
so politico is already paving the way
for election results not to be
not to be respected in iowa wow you mean
nancy pelosi might actually set aside
election results with the help of her
democratic friend
so as to ensure that a seat remains
democratic in iowa why would that
does that count as undermining democracy
or not just just for the record is that
undermining democracy or not
so good times in these in these voting
systems
okay and all of this brings us to the
latest with regard to president trump's
election legal moves and
and where we currently stand we'll get
to all of that in just one minute first
let us talk about the fact that malware
is a really really bad thing if you've
ever had malware on your computer it's
just a nightmare
and you you get ransomware on your
computer they lock up all your files
they
try to get you to give them your credit
card so you can unlock your files
or you get mailer on your computer it
completely wrecks your computer cost you
a couple thousand bucks to either fix or
get a new computer it's awful
hey pcmatic will protect you it's a
next-generation anti-virus designed to
stop modern threats like ransomware
independent testing from a v test just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry giving it the
best performance award for 2019.
only pcmatic has american research
development and support pcmatic's
competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates pcmatic blocks annoying and
malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing
and makes your computers faster and more
reliable even after years of use
pcmatic protects windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets
in fact pcmatic is just 50 bucks for
five devices for one year with a full 30
day money back guarantee if you act
right now
pcmatic has offered my listeners a free
month of security protection with the
purchase
of an annual license to access this
offer head on over to pcmatic.com
ben again to get the world-class
security that keeps your computer
running great go to pcmatic.com that is
pcmatic.com
ben we're gonna get to everything
election related in just
one second plus the latest in the
culture wars but if you're not already a
daily wire member now would be the time
to join we've got some
great stuff that is right around the
corner starting this friday december 4th
the michael knowles show is going five
days a week wait
what now i'm just learning about this
now
with more content for our members to
enjoy we're also adding
the entire prageru catalog to
dailywire.com by the end of the year
we've already uploaded all of the
prageru five minute videos the candace
owens show from prageru michael moles
book club
and the rest of the library is being
added as we speak that's a good thing
because youtube has been taking some of
those videos down
early next year candace owens is moving
to nashville to join us here at the
daily wire she'll be launching a brand
new daily wire show in front of a live
studio audience we are pumped about that
plus we are launching our first feature
film under daily wires upcoming
entertainment channel
it's a legit film guys like with a legit
movie star it's pretty awesome we are
building a new investigative journalism
team
to replace the legacy media cartel so go
outside the narrative come over to
dailywire.com
subscribe we're loud opinionated we are
having a good time also
you have not yet ordered these yet check
out our daily wire christmas ornaments
yes that's all of us
including the jew all of the daily wire
hosts plus god king jeremy boring
as santa's adorable elves made out of
painted metal i don't know that much
about ornaments
but i suppose it's cute and um if you
really want
the grinning skull of andrew clavin
grinning out at you from your christmas
tree then this would be the time to get
it text christmas to 83 400 to get your
tree decorated today
they are going fast get yours right now
text christmas to 83 400
to get started you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so here is where things currently
stand so over the last
24 hours uh the head of the doj a.g bar
he has said that he has uncovered no
evidence of widespread voter fraud that
could change the outcome of the 2020
election now what he didn't say is there
is no voter fraud
because obviously in a country of 158
million voters which is how many people
voted in this last election cycle there
will be some voter fraud and there will
be some voter
irregularity he has said that we have
not seen evidence that would overcome
the
barriers the electoral barriers for
trump in places like michigan 150 000
vote differential or in pennsylvania
about an 82 000 vote differential or
wisconsin about a 20 000 vote
differential or georgia for about a 13
000 vote
differential rights it that that's what
barr is saying
and you know i would take bar at his
word on that given the fact that
bar is not exactly a trump opponent
right i mean bar has
has done a good job as a g following the
law
so barr immediately drew criticism from
the trump attorneys
uh the the trump attorneys put out a
statement in which they said with all
due respect to the ag
there hasn't been any semblance of a
department of justice investigation
which is kind of fair i mean the doj has
not been
doing a full-scale investigation we have
gathered ample evidence of illegal
voting in at least six states which
they've not examined we have many
witnesses swearing under oath they saw
crimes being committed in connection
with voter fraud
as far as we know not a single one has
been interviewed by the doj the justice
department also hasn't audited any
voting machines or used their subpoena
powers to determine the truth
nonetheless we'll continue our pursuit
of the truth through the judicial system
and state legislatures
and continue toward the constitution's
mandate and ensuring that every legal
vote is counted and every illegal vote
is not that is a rudy giuliani and jenna
ellis trump's legal team
now here is the thing if they wish to
actually overturn the results of the
election
it's not going to be enough to be doing
these sort of public-facing press
conferences with members of state
legislatures those state legislatures
are not going to vote to overturn the
results of the election it's just not
going to happen
let's be perfectly frank about this the
idea that republican legislatures in
places
like arizona or michigan or pennsylvania
are going to disenfranchise
what people think is the current count
in these places without evidence that
all those votes
are without real evidence that the votes
themselves have been tampered with
right without what we have right now
from the giuliani
ellis team really is a lot of
allegations of the possibility of vote
hampering
and we have certain allegations that
people think they have seen things but
they have not provided any supportive
evidence to back that up
if you think that republican
legislatures in those states are like
just as a realistic descriptive matter
not what they ought to do what they are
going to do if you think the
pennsylvania legislature or the michigan
state legislature
is going to disenfranchise millions of
its own voters in order
to throw out the the purported results
of those elections
on the basis of these sort of press
conferences that is wrong now does every
one of these allegations deserve to be
addressed
absolutely but they need to be brought
in court okay court court court this
needs to be brought in court as a matter
of process
if you want the election results changed
this cannot be done in front of these
hearings in front of a state legislature
they need to be brought in court there
are legal penalties and legal sanctions
brought for attorneys who make false
claims in court there are legal
sanctions that can be brought for people
who are going to be
saying false things in court so if
you're going to swear under oath and you
do that in some sort of hearing with the
state legislature yes theoretically they
could go after you for perjury the
likelihood of that is extraordinarily
low if you do it in court the likelihood
is higher that means that you actually
have skin in the game
so bring it in court right listen i
would love nothing better than for trump
to retain the white house come january
but you're gonna need to actually bring
the evidence in court at this point
so right now the trump campaign is
bringing some of these cases in court in
wisconsin
they filed a petition on tuesday
challenging wisconsin's presidential
vote results with the state supreme
court
the petition was submitted as trump
appointed u.s attorney general william
barr said the doj didn't find evidence
of widespread voter fraud sufficient to
overturn the election
the petition alleges that wisconsin
election officials were directed to fill
in missing information on ballot
envelopes
issued absentee ballots without
receiving applications and allowed
people
to improperly claim a confined absentee
voting status
the petition takes issue with election
officials in madison hosting an event
where officials collected and checked
ballots in city parks
not polling stations election law
experts said the case might have a
better chance than other recent lawsuits
the court is highly unlikely to grant
the campaign's request to invalidate 221
absentee ballots biden wisconsin by
about 20 000 votes this is one of the
cases
where there's actually a pretty good
case here
that election law was violated but the
question is is the proper remedy
to disenfranchise all of the absentee
voters
so trump team says yeah because we don't
know how many of those absentee voters
were actually victimized we don't know
what this
what the numbers here are and the courts
have basically said we're not going to
disenfranchise hundreds of thousands of
voters based on the speculative
possibility
that some of these people voted
illegitimately
so the the the fact that the
case is legally well predicated which
the wisconsin case appears to be better
predicated or the fact that for example
the pennsylvania case
that is being pushed by team trump is
well predicated does not mean the remedy
that is sought is going to be the remedy
that is actually provided
by a court so for example in
pennsylvania like this again there are
grounds
for these lawsuits the problem is that
the remedy that the
trump team wants which is over from the
election results i mean frankly speaking
courts are unlikely to grant it
okay but here is uh senator ted cruz
pointing out that the supreme court
should take up an emergency appeal filed
in the supreme court challenging
election results in pennsylvania
he points out the pennsylvania
constitution requires in-person voting
except in narrow and defined
circumstances
late last year the pennsylvania
legislature passed a law that purported
to allow universal mail in voting
notwithstanding the pennsylvania
constitution's express prohibition
this appeal argues pennsylvania cannot
change the rules in the middle of the
game
if pennsylvania wants to change how
voting occurs the state must follow the
law
to do so okay now that is not wrong
that is not wrong right he says
ordinarily the u.s supreme court would
stay out of election disputes especially
concerning state law these are not
ordinary times
so yeah the case that the pennsylvania
supreme court and some of the federal
courts have made
is this an internal pennsylvania issue
the pennsylvania supreme court gets to
determine the voting procedures along
with the legislature
this really is not up to the federal
supreme court
for example but with that said a
well-predicated lawsuit right a lawsuit
that has
some legit claims that does not
necessarily mean that the remedy that
you seek is going to be the remedy that
you actually get
meanwhile in arizona uh there was a
small victory
for the arizona republican party
according to the arizona mirror
arizona republican party chair kelly
ward's attempt to invalidate nearly 1.7
million votes for joe biden will begin
with 200 ballots she and her attorneys
search for evidence of election fraud or
misconduct they have thus far been
they have thus far been able to show
ward is asking a maricopa county
superior court judge to declare trump
the rightful winner of arizona's 11
electoral votes
even though trump is down in the count
by about 10 000 votes she says election
workers didn't allow republican
observers to get close enough to ensure
signatures weren't mistakenly verified
she has yet to provide evidence that
there were duplicated ballots or that
ballots were changed
but she is asking a judge to allow them
to expect inspect tens of thousands of
ballots to see whether election workers
actually intervened on a one-to-one
level
now as doug ducey of arizona said that
is highly unlikely you have democrats
and republicans in the room verifying
these signatures
with that said the judge did agree to
let ward look at 100 envelopes and 100
duplicated ballots to see if there were
any
red flags they'll have until thursday to
see whether that drags up any
information
and again it's not as though the team
trump is not putting forward
some people who are claiming voter
regularity and voter fraud
for example they they had one of these
hearings in front of
republican state legislators in michigan
yesterday a michigan poll watcher
explained that he that he saw
republicans being ejected from rooms
throughout the day
i am an unaffiliated michigan voter who
uh was trained by the gop
to be a poll challenger on wednesday
november 4th beginning in the late
morning until around 8 pm
because i was told that they needed help
they didn't have they were understaffed
i witnessed the room erupt in thunderous
applause and derogatory cheering as
republican poll workers
were picked off one by one and ejected
from the room repeatedly
by police escort throughout the day by
the end of the day they had picked off
so many
gop poll workers that there were
probably only a few dozen left to
monitor all of the processing stations
in the room
which i'm told was between 130 and 160.
okay so
again he would need some supporting
evidence to demonstrate this would not
be one affidavit you need a bunch of the
poll workers at that particular
station to say that and you'd presumably
need somebody inside the room saying
that the remaining poll workers were
actually
changing the outcomes of the ballot
right and presumably you could do a hand
recount the way they did in georgia and
you could actually see whether the
printed out ballots
in person for example measured up to
dominion voting machines which is what
happened
in georgia so what is true and what is
false here the truth is there are people
who are making
pretty significant allegations what has
to happen is they need to make them in
court where they can actually be
properly adjudicated again
if you if you don't just want the cppr
campaign then you actually need the
process
to play out and you need to do this in
court it is not going
doing these things in front of the
oversight committee at the michigan
legislature
is not going to accomplish trump's goal
of getting the michigan election
overturned
it's just just being realistic with you
that's not going to happen the only
thing that is going to happen here
is if you can bring evidence in court
sufficient to prove your case
the wall street journal points out at
least some of the claims that are being
made
uh are you know being overstated for
example
so for example they point out that you
know there's a lot of talk about ballot
dumping like late night ballot dumping
but the fact is a lot of these states
didn't follow florida's procedure so
florida
allowed the tabulation of mail-in
balloting before the actual election day
that meant that instead of you getting
these late night ballot processing dumps
instead of that you actually had
everything tabulated up front and then
the mail-in ballots
came in early and then you had the
actual day of balloting and that came in
and within like an hour and a half we
knew exactly what was going on in
florida
unfortunately it was republican
legislatures in these areas that
actually
stopped the early tabulation of mainland
voting presumably because they were
afraid that the numbers would leak and
it might discourage republican votes
when it comes to when it comes to poll
watching according to the wall street
journal judges have dismissed affidavits
submitted by the trump camp
as rife with speculation and guesswork
and inadmissible as hearsay
other claims made in public circulate
largely without being tested a poll
watcher from delaware county
pennsylvania alleged last week that 47
usb cards used in the election are
missing and they're nowhere to be found
there was no proof laureen hagan the
chief elections clerk in delaware county
said were aware of the allegations but
all votes on scanners have all been
accounted for
meanwhile people who continue to claim
that dominion was hacked and the
dominion voting systems are the problem
the the evidence on that is really
really scanty because the totals
from georgia's hand recount using
dominion systems were basically
exactly right also it just happens to be
true
that dominion is not a venezuelan
creation the claims that were being made
by sydney powell were so crazy
that even the trump legal team decided
we are just not going to be complicit in
them right i mean cindy powell got
tossed off the team
after the big kraken speech just last
week
there's an editorial in the wall street
journal by a person named john paulus
who is one of the people he's the
president and ceo of dominion voting
systems
talking about some of the claims with
regard to with regard to dominion voting
systems
and rebutting some of them he says
dominion's an american company
headquartered in denver it has no ties
to hugo chavo's it has never been
involved in venezuelan elections
none of dominion systems use the
smartmatic software that has come under
attack as any state certification lab
could verify there's no vote-flipping
algorithm
third-party test labs chosen by the
bipartisan election assistance
commission
accredited by a program of the national
institute of standards and technology
perform complete source code reviews on
every federally certified tabulation
system
states replicate the process for their
own certifications post-election
canvassing and auditing also exist
to provide additional assurance of the
vote total accuracy
he also points out the tabulation
machines are tested publicly before
bipartisan witnesses before and right
after election day
on election day poll workers verify
voter identity including signature check
voters mark a paper ballot to vote
absentee voters use pens and person
voters use ballot marking
devices in both cases voters verify the
mark's paper ballot before casting it in
a secure ballot box through an
air-gapped scanning tabulator i know
because they use dominion systems
i believe here in florida and so when i
voted this was how the system worked
the georgia secretary of state's office
certified election results after hand
auditing 5 million ballots
showing the paper ballot voting system
counted and reported results accurately
okay so if we're going to you know get
any sort of
election change here then you're going
to actually have to show
widespread evidence not just speculative
possibility the speculative possibility
leads to a lot of incredible incredulity
about the results in public
maybe that's the point maybe that's not
the point but if you want the election
results overturned
what you actually need is to show the
evidence in court
and i will say that everybody on both
sides of the house should be pretty
unified in the basic idea
that can we stop like there are people
who are nuts out there like really nuts
stop threatening people you know people
who work at dominion voting systems
people who work at the georgia secretary
of state
office okay stop with that crap like
really it's not
this is a civilized society no matter
your side of the aisle as a person who's
received his fair share of death threats
that's garbage obviously so i will say
so
that number one number two are we going
to suggest that
trump is responsible for that because
he's casting doubt on the elections
again i have a very hard time with
all of the rhetoric suggesting that when
a president says something he is then
directly responsible for people doing
bad things with the things that he says
so georgia's voting systems manager got
him gabriel sherman yesterday he did a
press conference where he went after
trump suggesting
that threats of violence are due to
trump okay unless trump is threatening
violence
that's not due to trump trump can be
saying things that i disagree with
he can be saying things i think are not
true that does not mean that he is
responsible for violence any more than
bernie sanders who routinely says on
true things about the american health
care system
is responsible for acts of violence done
to republican congress people
it has to stop
mr president you have not condemned
these actions or this language
[Music]
senators you have not condemned this
language or these actions
this has to stop we need you to step
up and if you're gonna take a position
of leadership show some
okay i mean has anybody defended the
language like seriously who's defending
the language if they are
they should not be obviously okay
meanwhile in other big news william barr
the ag he has appointed the uh his
appointed john durham special counsel
this is a real troll move and it's
pretty awesome
so john durham is of course the special
counsel who has been
investigating the operation crossfire
hurricane
beginning right that is the fbi
investigation into trump-russia
collusion
and durham has been investigating the
origins to look at the fbi conduct
so william barr apparently shortly
before the election
he appointed john durham as a special
counsel
so that he could complete his work
without being easily fired according to
the ap under the regulations a special
counsel can be fired only by the
attorney general and for specific
reasons such as misconduct direction of
duty or conflict of interest
an attorney general must document such
reasons in writing
so believe it or not adam schiff came
out and he was like we should fire john
durham
so remember that time when adam schiff
was saying that robert mueller
should never ever ever be fired and that
firing robert mueller would be the worst
thing in the entire world
i agreed by the way that it would be a
bad move for trump to fire robert
mueller because i thought he would come
up empty which he did
kevin adam schiff was saying like we can
never he's a special investigator you
cannot fire your own special counsel
that
can't be done you can't fire robert
mueller that would be super bad now
adam's just like
maybe we should get rid of this john
durham guy you know he's looking into
the investiga he's looking into
how this whole russian collusion crap
got started what if we just fired him
like do we really need to pay attention
to
the special counsel rules how about let
the investigation go forward
how about let it move forward naturally
jerry nadler
democrat of new york and head of the
house judiciary committee said the
appointment erodes trust in the doj
you question how it was allowed under
the special counsel rules he said we
should not lose sight of the larger
picture
in the waning days of the trump
administration the ag has once again
used the powers of his office to settle
old scores
for the president the special counsel
rules say the appointed person should be
outside of government
bar pointed to specific provisions in
his memo that would allow him to go
around
that rule a senior doj official told the
ap although the order details it is
including but not limited to crossfire
hurricane
the durham probe has not expanded at
this point but hey
the rules are special counsel gets to do
whatever he wants those rules were not
created
by the republicans at this point they
were created by the democrats with
regard to robert mueller so now
democrats are going to have to live
with those consequences meanwhile
democrats continue to hold up
a coveted relief package so republicans
right now
are trying to move through a coveted
relief package mitch mcconnell
has been having a little bit trouble
locking down republican support i think
he will get it
pushing a new relief package that
amounts to just under a trillion dollars
according to cnn mcconnell has been in
private discussions with house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
treasury secretary steve mnuchin and the
white house chief of staff mark meadows
getting a clear sense of what president
trump is willing to sign into law in his
final days in office
as mcconnell drafts a new bill based on
those conversations democratic leaders
are making
their own counter offer to jump start
the talks
sure they are all they would have to do
by the way is just pass this thing
mcconnell said the one thing we all
agree on we don't have time for
messaging games
we don't have time for lengthy
negotiation the issue is we want to get
a result
i like to remind everybody the way you
get a result is you have a presidential
signature
so meanwhile mcconnell uh has uh
has been pushing this 908 billion
bipartisan plan a group of senators
introduced on tuesday and um
some of the democrats are on board right
chris murphy democrat from connecticut
he said let's do it let's get this done
it's a really positive
development and this amount of money
could get us through
what is likely to be a very hard and
very deadly winter
uh this isn't big enough to be able to
uh get us to the point where the entire
country is vaccinated but it
might be enough to make sure that
millions of americans
don't go hungry don't starve don't die
out on the streets this winter when
their jobless benefits expire and when
protections for evictions
expire okay so um
we have democrats on board and mitt
romney is on board right mitt romney
says this is a crisis i'm not big on
spending but you have to pass something
so you have a 14
senator group that is proposing this
bill and mitch mcconnell is starting to
push this bill too so what exactly is
the hold up the democrats or is mitt
romney
pushing it we've got people unemployed
we've got businesses shutting down
we've got states and localities getting
ready for layoffs of large numbers of
people it's simply unacceptable
for us not to respond to help in this
circumstance now i
happen to be a deficit hawk i don't like
borrowing money
i don't like spending money we don't
have but the time to borrow money
maybe the only time to buy money is what
borrow money is when there's a crisis
and this is a crisis we want to help
people
at this particular time well one problem
democrats are holding this
thing up republican lawmakers according
to fox news condemned house speaker
nancy pelosi after democratic leadership
announced a bill to federally legalize
marijuana will hit the house floor on
wednesday
house majority leader steiny hoyer
democrat of maryland said the chamber
will be considering multiple more bills
including the marijuana opportunity
reinvestment and expungement act the
more act
great and voting will take place
wednesday through friday also
there will be another bill reviewed
seeking to ban breeding and private
ownership of big cats
because everybody watched tiger king
over the pandemic
republicans were like um what are you
doing now kevin mccarthy tweeted out
this week your house majority democrats
they are tackling the tough issues by
holding a vote on legalizing pot and
banning tiger ownership
nothing for small businesses nothing for
reopening schools nothing on battling
the pandemic just cannabis and cats
steve scalise the house minority whip he
tweeted out let me get this straight
nancy pelosi is blocking a bill to
deliver unused paycheck protection
program funds to workers and small
businesses
but you managed to find time for a vote
on power legislation this week retweets
to tell democrats to quit blocking aid
for americans in need
right now remember this has been held up
by democrats for months stephen newton
basically went to pelosi and he was like
you know what whatever you want i am
happy to give it to you
and she's like you know what i'm just
going to ignore you right now until the
election is over it did not pay off to
her benefit by the way democrats did
really really poorly
in the house nonetheless they're still
holding this thing up
so just remember when you hear democrats
talking about how republicans are
responsible
for all of the harms of covenant 19 it
is democrats who are holding this thing
up
this is why when joe biden says help is
on the way for the economy i don't
believe you
i don't believe you in fact the best
hope for joe biden should he god forbid
take office in january
if joe biden is deemed president-elect
on december 14th by the electors
if joe biden takes office the the only
thing that will cut in joe biden's favor
if i were joe biden honestly i would be
rooting for republicans to win those two
senate seats in georgia
because that way i could proclaim that i
was all for these progressive priorities
that wrecked the economy
and then i would never be able to
implement them and then i would be
considered bipartisan because the
economy would be good
right that that would be your like joe
biden has to be rooting for his own
interests
to basically be cut against by the
presence of republican senate here was
joe biden
yesterday saying help was on the way for
the economy it was joe biden's brand of
help i think we can all be spared it
i know times are tough but i want you to
know that help
is on the way a first-rate team that's
going to get us through
this ongoing economic crisis and help us
build the economy back
not just build it back but build it back
better than it was before
a team that's tested and experienced it
includes groundbreaking americans who
come from different backgrounds
but who share my core vision for
economic
relief here in the united states of
america oh goody goody gumdrops
i i cannot wait for this doofus to start
intervening in the american economy by
the way there's a story that's going
around about the coveted relief package
like the first one the paycheck
protection program so remember
congress approved 521 billion dollars in
small business grants and loans under
the paycheck protection program
about 388 about 380 billion dollars went
out the door
so now people in the media they're going
nuts over the paycheck protection
program why
well first of all they're trying to
provide cover for democrats not passing
more of it
but what is their big complaint their
big complaint is they have now found
that over 25
paycheck protection program loans worth
then worth more than 3.65 million
dollars were given to businesses with
addresses at trump and kushner real
estate properties paying rent to the
owners
so these are not businesses owned by
trump or kushner these are businesses
that rent at real estate owned by trump
and kushner
so the idea is that the entire paycheck
protection program scheme
was a 500 billion dollar payout to
accomplish
three mil three million dollars given to
businesses that rent
from trump and kushner wow scandal of
scandals
you mean they own real estate and people
rent from them that's crazy
well i mean if they're renting from
kushner or renting at a trump property
that means they should not receive a
paycheck protection
program loan it's not like they have
employees it's not like they have bills
to pay
the loans to trump and kushner
properties included a 2 million
loan to the triumph restaurant
corporation located a trump
international hotel and tower in new
york city
the company reported the money didn't go
to keeping jobs and it later closed
okay is it owned by trump the triumph
restaurant corporation
is it owned by trump i missed that part
if the answer is no
who cares but this is apparently a very
big scandal again
just more pr done for the democrats on
the basis
of pseudo-reporting of nonsense
two tenants at 725 fifth avenue trump
tower received more than a hundred
thousand dollars
and only kept three jobs only kept how
many jobs were they supposed to keep
with a hundred thousand dollar grant
like what exactly are you paying people
i mean
it's such a non-scandal but of course
the media are covering it as though it
was a scandal
because they always have to fill the the
barrel
with with uh with scandal just
ridiculous ridiculous stuff
so are these folks going to fix the
economy uh i think i think not i think
the chances of that are very very
low okay again and by the way in more
bad media coverage quick note and more
bad media coverage so last night very
late last night
a story broke that was supposed to
bombshell and it was that there was the
doj was investigating a possible
criminal bribery scheme for a
presidential pardon
okay and the media immediately went nuts
this means someone inside the white
house was going to be bribed to get
trump to give a pardon
he's going to be just like mark rich
except how markrich was totally fine
that was totally fine with bill clinton
don't look over there it wasn't like
mark wretch on second thought but it's
really bad it's like a bribery scheme
right and probably it's gonna ensnare
finally they'll get trump even as he's
leaving they'll frog march him out
then the doj comes out like well
actually no government official was or
is currently a subject or target of the
investigation disclosed
in this filing whoops so for like
several hours last night it was all
people could talk about
did somebody bribe trump for a pardon
and then the doj is like no
most of that document's redacted you
guys are just filling in the gaps what
you wish were there
it ain't there well done the media but
clowning itself once again
okay now i would be remiss today if i
did not discuss
one of the great issues of our time and
that is that the actress ellen page
who is was and shall remain a woman is
now a man
so let me read you the headline from cnn
which conveys zero information
and we have now been forced as a society
to simply say nonsense
to simply just say things that are
nonsense that don't make any sort of
logical sense
that don't actually translate from
english
to reason okay so here is the headline
and you tell me if you know
what the hell this means okay ready
elliot page junostar
shares transgender identity do you have
any idea what that means
like seriously do you have any idea that
means when i first saw the headline
elliott page i thought whoa ellen has a
brother
no it turns out that ellen page is now
identifying as elliot page
and the media instead of saying here's a
headline with content ellen page
announces she identifies as man wishes
to be called
elliott page right now i would have the
whole story but elliot page junostar
conveys nothing because ellen page was
the star of juno
so i'm like wait was her brother in that
movie like i don't even know what you're
talking about right now
because the media have created this
bizarre
standard whereby if a person declares
themselves a member of the opposite
gender the entire world
especially in the media must immediately
flip on a dime stop calling them by the
name everybody knew them as and stop
calling them by their biological sex
you end up with complete nonsense just
complete bl
coming out of the mouths of the media
now listen ellen page can identify
however she wants i don't care
really it makes no difference to me
she's an adult human she can do whatever
she wants it is a free country
however it being a free country i am
also free to point out that ellen page
is was and shall remain a woman because
ellen page is in fact a woman
now i'm happy to call ellen page elliott
if she wants to be called elliot because
people change their names all the time
and you can in fact change your name by
declaration
you cannot however change your sex by
declaration or your gender by
declaration that is not how this works
there is no other area of life
in which people simply declare
themselves to be a thing and everybody
goes oh
okay right an objectively verifiable
thing
right there you can declare your sexual
orientation where you can declare a
thing that you like
you can declare that you're a fan of
this particular band you can declare
that you have a sexual attraction to x y
or z right that's all subjective
and all we have to go on is your
behavior which is objective and your
subjective self-assessment
however when you're declaring something
as core as your sex
there is no objectifiable no objective
measure whatsoever
whereby ellen page is a man none right
she is a woman
and yet we are immediately told by the
media that you even address
ellen page or elliott page as a
she is discriminatory it's very bad and
very discriminatory and so you end up
with
complete inanities and insanities okay
so
ellen page declared that she is now a
man
okay but she also declared that she is a
queer man
now this is confusing because if she
were a queer man this would mean that
she is attracted to men
which would technically mean that she's
a straight woman right because if she is
an actual woman attracted to men this
would make her a straight woman but we
know she's not
that because she was a lesbian right so
she is
married to a woman as far as i'm aware
and that means that she is
a lesbian but now she is a man and
according to her this means that she is
a white
straight male so how's she queer she's a
white straight male
so here is how wikipedia tries to sum
this up you ready for this
according to wikipedia in
in january 2018 page publicly announced
his marriage to dancer and choreographer
emma portner so this means
that ellen page is a gay man married to
a woman according to wikipedia
which makes no sense at all like
in any way shape or form and you're
expected to simply mirror this
not only that the left has particular
standards with regard to who gets to
play parts and movies so for example
ellen page now now elliott page right
i'm saying ellen page not because i wish
to offend elliot page but because
until five seconds ago nobody had ever
heard of eliot page nobody knows who the
hell i'm talking about so i'm going to
use the name that people know her as
and then over time if you want to call
it la page that's fine but for like
today
i feel like it's fair to mention that
ellen page and elliott page are the same
person so that if somebody tunes in and
hears elliott page they don't think
ellen has a brother
okay so here's the headline from tv
insider
elliot page reportedly con to continue
in same role on umbrella academy
now umbrella academy on netflix uh it
started off that the series itself
is based on a comic book in the comic
book ellen page
who again is a woman and is in the
series a cisgender woman
right like a woman who is a woman is a
uh
is a straight woman in the first season
in the second season ellen page
becomes a lesbian because ellen page is
a lesbian in real life i guess
um i mean i assume that's that's what
the plan was there and that it has
something to do with
how ellen page wanted to act because my
understanding is that's not something
directly from the comic book series if
it is forgive me that's fine who cares
okay but here's the part that's
hilarious so according to
variety they say there are no plans to
change
the character ellen page plays her
gender
on the umbrella academy so the series is
publicly showing their support
and they say they are proud of their
superhero
we love you elliot but elliott will be
playing a woman
now i've been firmly informed that this
is discrimination and cultural
appropriation
when scarlett johansson a straight woman
was slated to play a transgender man
in a movie this was considered very very
bad form
in fact only trans people could play
trans characters so i have a question
if elliot page is in fact a man the way
that the media have declared that she is
a man
then why is she allowed to play a
cisgender woman is that not cultural
appropriation
if a normal non-trans man decided to
play a woman today
everybody would suggest that this was a
violation of long-standing norms it was
cultural appropriation
but if a woman declares herself a man
then you have to make a choice either
she is a man in which case she can't
play a woman anymore or she is not a man
in which case she's not a man
but because our culture is unbelievably
stupid it is both right that is the way
that this works
so good news elliot page can still play
women
and also can play transgender men
presumably can also play
men men which is really exciting one
further note on all of this if you feel
like this is crazy and this is being
crammed down on you that is because it
is
that is because this is not a fringe
phenomenon anymore
right this is something the democratic
party fully embraces and pushes
yesterday chuck schumer the senate
minority leader
he said that he is fully with joe biden
on mandating
from the federal government that
transgender people be allowed to use the
bathroom of their choice
now it seems to me that if my wife is
uncomfortable
with a male walking into a bathroom or a
locker room where she is undressing at
the gym
that that is perfectly within her
purview that seems like not
inappropriate at all to me
but the federal government has now
decided under democratic auspices that
men and women
are exactly the same that gender is
completely fluid
none of this makes any internal sense by
the way if men and women are completely
same
the same there's no reason for yourself
for you to declare yourself a man that
man equals woman means woman equals
woman
right i mean it's just the basic
transitive property in any case here is
chuck schumer
you know fully green lighting the
democratic agenda which is fully in line
with all this this silliness and
anti-logic nonsense and again
ellen page or elliot page is allowed to
do whatever she wants to do today but
she does not get to dictate what the
rest of us
say about things as basic as biological
sex and capital t
truth okay but here is uh here's the
democratic party pushing this stuff
joe biden said that on his first day of
office he will give transgender students
access to sports bathrooms and locker
rooms in accordance with their gender
identity in all federally funded schools
do you think he has the ability to do
this and do you agree with this decision
i agree with the decision and i know
he'll check things out thoroughly
legally
okay i'm sure that this will all work
out just fantastically well i'm sure
and don't feel bullied don't feel as
though you are being forced to
change long standing and for all of
human history held opinions
about the non-malleability of sex uh it
is all because
you're discriminatory in your mind don't
worry about the fact that this is all
illogical it makes no sense the media
have told you that a thing is so and
therefore it is so
and therefore and also if you mention it
it's because you are
it's because you're obsessed with these
issues this is one of my favorites is
that
you say something is radical as men and
women are exactly the same in a man can
become a woman and then i say no
they're like why are you even paying
attention to this why are you making an
issue out of this
i'm not you guys are i'm sorry but you
purveyors of
new truths that have nothing to do with
science logic
reason the answer is no the answer is no
i do not go along
with your with your mandatory take on
the world and i don't think americans
should either that's not an excuse for
being nasty to people it's not an excuse
for discrimination
it is a recommendation that we all speak
real truths when they are available
and it happens to be a real truth that
elliot page is was and will remain a
woman
even if elliot page believes that she is
a man and you're under no obligation
moral or otherwise to suggest that men
can become women or to teach that to
your children which is really what the
left wants out of this whole deal in the
end
all right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matte wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen